- Hi, everyone. Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Homeroom,
I guess we say live stream and podcast.
Although we are pre-recording
today's session.
First of all, Happy
International Women's Day.
And we have a very exciting guest today
to talk about her life and
the internet and YouTube,
Susan Wojcicki, who is the CEO of YouTube,
a small website that
you might have heard of
that has to deal with videos.
But before we jump into that conversation
where we talk about all of those things
I will give my standard reminders.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization,
and we can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up,
especially during the pandemic,
when they realized that
Khan Academy's traffic
was three times normal,
and we were running at a deficit,
and we wanted to accelerate
a whole bunch of things
to support more folks.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and General Motors
for stepping up and
helping us fill that gap.
But we still need more support,
especially as we go into 2021.
So anything you can do
is much appreciated.
And then the last announcement,
there was a version of
this of this live stream
that you can get in podcast form,
wherever you get your podcasts.
Homeroom with Sal the Podcast.
So with that, I am excited
to introduce Susan Wojcicki.
Susan, good to see you.
- Thank you for having me, Sal.
It's good to be here.
- Great to have you here.
And you know, we've known
each other for a while.
You know, I've been known to
do a few things on YouTube.
- We've known each other
for many, many years.
I can't even remember when we first met.
It's been so long.
- Oh, it's probably on
the order of 10 years,
and I know your mother.
We don't live too far
away from each other.
Well, there's so much I
wanna talk to you about.
I think most people know about YouTube,
but I think it's always
interesting to hear about
the organization from
the CEO's point of view,
especially what do you hope it becomes.
So what's your best sense
of the mission of YouTube,
or what do you think it
can become over the next,
let's say, 10 years?
- Yeah. Well, so we have a mission.
So I'll tell you what the mission is,
which is to give everyone a
voice and show them the world.
And so if you look at the first part,
to give everyone a voice,
how do we enable anyone who
wants to share something
with the world,
how to enable them to do that?
So, I think YouTube has
really made a lot of...
We've been revolutionary
in many ways, right?
We have millions of channels and creators,
but we still have a lot of work to do
to continue to enable
people all over the world
to create video and make it easier,
and continue to grow that,
but show them the world.
I think that's actually
where we're really aligned
in terms of our mission,
so that people everywhere
can come to YouTube
and learn anything they want,
or experience any kind
of music, entertainment,
look up any kind of information.
And so I've also said that
YouTube, in some ways,
is like a public video library,
and we keep growing and growing
in terms of offering new topics
and we have books from like books,
like videos from new people.
And our goal is just to
continue to be a resource
for people around the world to learn.
And I've been really inspired by that.
I sometimes see in different
parts of the world,
wherever I go,
people tell me what
they learned on YouTube.
So that's something we
wanna continue to grow.
- I think that's the surprising thing.
You know, when YouTube was just starting
to get off the ground
and people started to associate it with,
you know, just entertainment,
but very quickly humanity
realized that kind of
knowledge could be shared.
And I actually think YouTube
will go down in world history
as a moment in human history,
where for, you know,
humans are separate themselves
from the rest of the animal
kingdom by having culture
and having shared knowledge,
which for many tens of thousands of years
happened through an oral tradition,
then we invented a writing,
and then that allowed it to persist,
and not kind of lose information
as that information spread,
but writing loses a
little bit of the oral.
And now with on-demand video and YouTube
and mass distribution of it,
you kind of have all of the above,
that any one person can express their oral
or their video or the visual
tradition and their knowledge,
and then it's literally available
to every human being on the planet.
Do you all ever view yourself that way,
as like the globe's,
I guess you did say it's the library,
it's the brain,
the knowledge of humanity
is literally on YouTube.
- I definitely see the impact,
because people everywhere
tell me what they learn,
and especially now, during the pandemic,
we played a really key role.
A lot of people had to do
things for the first time,
like fix something in their
house, give a haircut,
learn a new skill.
And the fact that YouTube could do that
and could be there in
that moment of crisis
was really, really valuable.
So I definitely understand that,
and our goal is to continue to grow that
and support those use cases,
so everybody can have that resource.
- Absolutely, and obviously,
most people who are watching this,
many of them who are
watching it on YouTube,
know that, you know, I showed
up on people's radar...
You know, Khan Academy
has a lot of things.
We have videos and exercises,
but it's the YouTube
that really helped people
know what we're all about,
and was an easy way to discover.
You mentioned haircuts.
My wife watched a couple
of YouTube videos,
and, you know, I think it's...
You know, my hair has issues,
but it's one of the better
haircuts that I've gotten.
And I've fixed a toilet.
I fixed the toilet twice
over the last nine months
based on YouTube videos.
And I think they're working.
So that's absolutely true.
You know, on the other
side of that though,
there's a lot of conversation
about misinformation and
the spreading of, you know,
how people get into their own silos.
How do y'all think about that on YouTube?
How do y'all try to make sense of people
who are spreading misinformation,
or, you know, people just
gravitating to things
that already confirm whatever
biases they might have?
- So great question and
really important question.
And we've put a huge amount of effort
to figure out the right
solutions for that.
And so basically we
talk about all this work
around responsibility.
And so we have what we call
the four Rs of responsibility.
And the first one is about content
that we would remove
if it is content that we think could lead
to real-world harm.
So like, let's just talk about COVID,
just to put this in perspective.
So there were different
conspiracies that came out,
like one of them was that
COVID came from 5G cell towers,
and it goes against all consensus,
from medical consensus.
And so that was something
where we would say,
"That's clearly not true."
We need to remove it,
because people were
destroying cell towers,
and we also don't want people to go out
and then do risky behavior.
So we are able to work
with medical professionals
to find content
that was clearly violative.
And again, we work with the
medical professionals on that.
But then we also raised up information,
so information that we
knew that was accurate.
So like how to wash your hands.
I never thought we'd serve so many
how to wash your hand videos.
We worked with 85 different
health professional organizations
from around the world,
and we made sure that all of
that information was delivered.
So whether you did a search,
whether you watched the video,
you could link and you could
see authoritative information.
And then there's some content
that's just borderline,
like it might be something that
isn't really a big problem,
but it's low quality.
And that's just something
that we are less likely
to recommend to our users,
because we wanna give them
high quality information.
We don't want them to
come and see something
that says like, "Aliens
landed in your backyard."
That's very unlikely.
And so, again, we don't
want to go too far,
and say, hey, we're
restricting free speech,
because that's very important too,
that we can enable a broad set
of opinions and perspectives.
So we also are reducing
information that is low quality
in terms of how we handle
that in our recommendations.
- No, that last point, I
always like to clarify,
whenever people say that, you know,
this is reducing free speech,
I was like, "You know, free speech
is the right to say things that,
first of all, you know, somehow
do not undermine government
or would hurt people,
but you have the right to say it,
but you don't have the right to for it
to be amplified by other media companies."
If you go back 100 years ago,
I could say whatever I want,
I could complain about government,
or come up with conspiracy theories,
but it doesn't mean
that the New York Times
have to publish whatever I had to say.
And there's an analogy now
that it does not have to be validated,
or you don't have the
right to be amplified.
So I think it's an interesting nuance.
Yes, you can't be arrested for coming up
with a conspiracy theory,
but you can't just spread it willy nilly,
and say, "That's my right.
You know, I would love to dig a little bit
into your journey to
becoming CEO of YouTube.
We have a lot of young
people who watch this.
It's International Women's Day.
I think there's a lot of young women
who look up to you as a
real leader in industry
across the board.
When you were young, what were you like,
and is this what you thought
you were going to do?
- No, I had no idea
this is what I was gonna do.
And maybe I'm showing
my age by saying this,
but we didn't have the
internet when I was young,
so I couldn't have even imagined that.
And I mean, I think as a young kid,
what was I like?
First of all, I was really
into doing arts and crafts.
I was really into being creative
and making things,
like I would make paper and pot holders.
My first business was making spice ropes
and selling them to my neighbor.
So I just like to make stuff.
- What's a spice rope?
- I would braid yarn and then
tie cinnamon sticks to it
and take colored fabric
and put spices in there.
And I just would make stuff.
And for me, I had this realization
that technology was about creation.
It was about making things
and creating things.
A lot of people didn't seem to see that,
especially not then,
but I totally got it.
I was like, "Wow, I can make all kinds
of really interesting software,
and it can be distributed,
and so, so many people can see it
and they can use it and
I can interact with them.
And once I got that idea,
I just said like, "Oh,
I have to be in tech.
This is the best field for me
based on all my interests
with the creativity and making things,
and seeing how I could
have an impact that way."
I didn't know where it was gonna lead,
but as long as I was
making things, I was happy,
and that's what got me started in tech.
- No, very similar to me.
It's all about this notion of creation,
and that you can create things
that have incredible scale,
incredible impact.
And once you went into tech,
what did you think you
were gonna actually...
How did you get started?
Did you take a traditional
software engineering route?
Connect the dots between
this interest in creation
and where you are now.
- Well, I took a computer science class
my senior year in college.
I took the computer science
for computer science majors,
At the time I thought, "Oh, it's too late.
Oh, I'm too old."
Like, I was a humanities major,
so I was like, "I must be
too old to change careers,"
'cause I was--
- I find it funny when a 20-year-old
says they're too old, 21.
- I thought I was too old,
as 20 or 21-year-old, to start
learning computer science,
'cause I had friends and they were majors,
and they had taken it for three years,
and we were all about to graduate.
But I realized that I
wanted to do something
in computer science.
And so that was my first role,
or that was my first, you know,
that's when I was academically engaged
with computer science,
and then I grew up in the Palo Alto area.
So I think that probably
had something to do with it.
And I came back after college,
and I wound up working at this
educational software startup.
So here I am, Sal,
I don't know, many, many years later,
working with you around education.
So I had that interest then.
I still have that interest now,
but I was just a project manager
for making software for
kids around education,
and I loved it.
It was creation.
Kids would write about
how they use the software,
how they learn something
and the impact it had.
And so I just said like,
"This is what I'm gonna do.
I'm so committed to this."
I can keep going. You wanna know more?
- No, I do. I actually never
knew about this chapter.
I mean, I'm especially curious
about what do you think it
was that you told yourself
or the skills that you brought
to the table that allowed
you to really thrive
in this world,
and obviously, you know, keep
rising through the ranks?
You know, you joined Google
at a very early stage,
and then now as CEO of YouTube,
you know, I know it's a
hard question to answer,
'cause you're a humble person,
but be not so humble for a few seconds.
- Sure.
If I look back at my career,
there were a few key things
that really helped me.
One of them was, first of all,
I was just looking to do
something interesting.
I was just thinking,
"How can I use my skills
to help create something
that will be used by people,
and that will be useful
and make the world a better place?
And when I joined Google,
I was in place 16 of Google.
When I joined Google,
nobody thought that Google
was that interesting of a company,
but I saw that it was enabling people
to find information in new ways.
And so being able to just
focus on what was important,
what I saw was adding value,
whether or not other people agreed or not,
was part of what helped me.
I think it was the same thing for YouTube.
When I first started working on YouTube,
nobody thought it was that big a deal.
They thought it was a small little company
with like a lot of cats on skateboards.
It wasn't really going anywhere,
but I saw that people could use it
for creating and sharing ideas,
and information,
and new musicians and
artists and creators.
So seeing ideas early
and believing in them
has definitely helped me.
But then I would say there's a part two,
which was maybe less inspiration
and more perspiration,
which is just sticking with it,
and working hard and not giving up,
and getting through all the hard times,
and just sticking with it,
keep working on it, keep
waking up every day,
thinking about how you can
make the company better,
and add value,
and get through the tough times.
So I'd say that those
are the two key parts,
the inspiration and the perspiration.
- It makes a lot of sense.
And I have so many questions for you,
but I know we have a lot of questions
that have come in
appropriately for you on video.
So the first question
we have is from Izzy,
if we could watch that video.
- I was wondering what you wanted to do
when you were my age.
And did you ever think you'd
be the CEO of a huge company?
- No, I never thought I'd would be the CEO
of a huge company.
And when I was your age,
I probably wanted to...
I was just interested in
a lot of different things.
I didn't really know what
the future held for me,
but I was interested in arts and crafts.
I was interested in science.
I was interested in entrepreneurship.
I would just start things.
And like I said, I would make things
and sell it to my neighbors.
And all of those turned out in
the end to be useful skills.
So I just encourage all of
you to explore the world,
find what you love,
find the areas that you
wanna keep working on,
and that ultimately will
lead you to somewhere,
because to choose a career,
to choose a profession,
it has to be something
that is meaningful for you.
It'll be much easier and
you'll do a better job
if it's meaningful to you.
So choose something that
you enjoy doing every day,
and that you see benefits the world,
and that, ultimately,
you derive meaning from.
- Completely agree.
And the next question
we have is from Lily.
- For young women who are looking
into being in management
positions or positions of power,
what advice do you have for them
in trying to get past
those gender stereotypes
of being too pushy
or too bossy when try
to achieve their goals?
- So there are definitely
a lot of challenges.
And some of the ways
that I have overcome them
is by, first of all, working really hard,
which I'm sure all of you do.
And also I'd say, with
some of the stereotypes,
or people maybe who are
maybe not as supportive,
I've tried to ignore the people
who might be less supportive
and make friends with the people who are.
And so I've found it really valuable
over the course of my career
to figure out who my allies are,
to work closely with them,
develop close relationships with them,
and just continue doing
the work that you're doing.
And I do think we're at a time
where companies are working really hard
to have diverse workforces,
because we recognize that diversity
makes a stronger company,
it makes a better product,
and I encourage all of you
to pursue your passions,
and just to continue to work hard,
and don't give up and find your allies.
And if you find someone
who's not supportive,
just do your best to, you know,
keep working through that.
And certainly, while there
are different stereotypes,
the stereotypes are always changing,
and I really hope by the time
that a lot of you grow up,
that some of the stereotypes you mentioned
are not anything that you
have to face in the future.
- And just following up on that,
you know, for those who don't know, Susan,
you and your siblings and your
mother are kind of famous.
You know, as sisters,
all of you have been wildly successful.
You know, you have a
sister who's a physician,
you have a sister who is a CEO of 23andMe.
Your mother is world
famous as an educator,
a journalism teacher,
et cetera, et cetera.
Is there something that
your mother gave you
or you had between your
yourselves as sisters
that you could share,
with kind of sisters around the world,
that really helped you?
- I wish I could say
it was just one thing,
but I do think the one thing
my mom gave to all of us
was certainly the focus on persistence,
believing in yourself and
not getting embarrassed.
So my mom was always the first person
to ask a hard question in an audience.
Like, she used to always
be the one who would say...
She felt like if she had been wrong,
she needed to speak up about it.
And sometimes as a kid, that
was really embarrassing,
but I learned over time,
it's really important to use your voice.
It's really important
to say what you believe
and to speak up for yourself.
And I do think that those
skills have helped all of us,
because if you believe in yourself,
you speak up for yourself,
but you're working hard
and doing a great job
of what you're doing,
you're gonna find a way to be successful.
And I think that we
learned a lot of skills
from my mom and my dad,
who's the professor,
and who was consistently hardworking,
and we learned that those
are all things that it takes.
And if you keep it up and work hard,
you'll end up with something
that is compelling for you.
- Yeah, well, we have another
question here from Imari.
- What are some activities or actions
that you recommend for
young women entering college
to prepare them for career success?
- So for career success,
for people who are entering college
or entering the workforce,
I would really encourage
you to think about
what is meaningful for you,
because it's very hard to do
a job that you don't like.
You have to find something
that really speaks to you.
And I see that among my own kids,
and all the kids that I work with,
that people come from
very different places.
And there are very different
passions that people have.
And so to the extent that
you can look inside yourself,
and think about what would
be really meaningful for you,
and find a way to explore that,
and that if your work
speaks to you in a deep way,
and you take meaning from it,
it will help you get
through the hard times.
It will help you stick with
it and make a difference.
So I encourage you just
to really think about
what your passions are,
and you have to be practical
too, realistically,
I think that's something I
learned from my mom also,
like, I would have probably said, oh.
If you had asked me as a kid,
I've always said, "Oh, I just
want to be like an artist,
and draw pictures,
and, you know, make candles,"
and as compelling as all of that is,
she also encouraged me like,
"Yes, you need to be
able to make a living.
You have to be able to do something
where you can support yourself."
So marrying the two of
what your passion is,
but where there's market and demand
for the things that you're interested in,
those are good places for you
to look at future careers.
And also encourage
people to look at things
that are growing.
Like, in many ways, I
benefited from being in tech,
which was a growing industry,
so there were always new jobs.
There was always something new to explore.
And so to the extent that
you can choose an area
that is expanding,
that's the whole area is growing,
it's gonna be easier to get more jobs.
It's going to be easier to get promoted.
So that's another thing to consider
as you factor your future career in
and what areas you're gonna go into.
- No, I love that advice.
I always tell folks,
actually, on one part of your brain,
you should be hyper pragmatic.
look at the industries that are growing,
that compensate well,
and that, you know, are bearable,
you can enjoy working in that,
but as you do that,
carve out some space to
also be hyper idealistic
and have your passions.
And we're in a unique time.
I mean, YouTube shows us this,
my narrative shows this,
your narrative shows this,
that those things will
intersect in surprising ways.
There's ways to publish your passions.
There's other people in the world
that will also have those passions,
and it can turn into a
career in and of itself.
There's another question here from Ruby.
- You must have faced a lot of obstacles
getting to where you are today,
and I'm wondering if you
ever felt like giving up.
If so, how were you able to
overcome that? Thank you.
- [Sal] Oh, great question.
- Yeah, great question.
I definitely have had hard days,
and there've been moments where
I have felt like giving up,
but I've often realized that if I give up,
well, then I don't get to
keep doing what I love doing.
And if I give up,
because someone was difficult,
well, then they win and
they get what they want,
and I don't get to continue to
make my points of view heard.
So I usually,
when I have a bad day,
I just call it a night
and I go to bed early,
and I wake up,
and most days, like, I
feel ready to do it again,
and ready to revisit the situation.
And I find a way to smooth
over whatever was really hard.
And I encourage you just
to find something you love
and stick with it.
- Yeah, and I always remind folks,
you know, there's no movie
where the protagonist does not
have to deal with adversity.
So whenever those adverse moments happen,
say, "Well, this is
just part of my movie."
And the movie would not be interesting
without these moments.
And you're absolutely right.
The things that you think
are existential crises,
you know, within reason,
a week later, you're like,
"I just have to power through it."
There's ways that it can
sometimes get better,
and you just have to
sometimes realize that it,
you know, staying in the
game is half the battle.
- Yeah, and I've had many times things
didn't go the way I wanted,
and many times things failed,
and many times I made mistakes,
and then I had to come back,
and say, "Oh, I learned from that."
That's how life is,
and what makes you stronger
is overcoming that,
and internalizing that,
and saying, "Well, what
did I learn from that?
And how can I change how
my life is going forward?"
And if you are continuously learning,
if you are having as many experiences,
and then benefiting from them,
and figuring out how you
can do everything better,
then that all adds up.
And there are a lot of
times where we're at work
and people come to me
with different ideas,
and be like,
I'll say, "I know about doing that,
'cause I did it and it didn't work."
I can tell you why,
'cause there are a lot of things I've done
that have not worked.
But I learned from it and
I'm not doing them again.
And I'm actually telling other people too,
like, don't do that.
Sometimes I'll even say,
"Hey, you know what?
You can try it, the world's different,
like, maybe things have changed."
And so I'm also open to how
something could be different now
than it was in the past.
But I tell them, like,
"This is why it didn't work for me,
you should take that into consideration
as you consider your future plans."
- You know, related to that,
when people look at
you, when I look at you,
you're like, oh, Susan Wojcicki,
you know, titan of tech,
has it all figured out,
she's made it.
What are the things that you feel
that you feel sometimes unsure about
or that you stress about?
Because I think that's something that,
you know, it's very easy...
We all know the things we stress about,
but when we look at the
Susan Wojcickis of the world,
like they have it figured out.
So, you know, show us that
you're like the rest of us.
- Well, there are definitely...
A lot of times I'm doing
things I've never done before,
just because tech is in a new place
that it's never been before,
and we're having to figure out a lot
of challenging situations
based on the size
or where we are and how we can do better.
And I mean, there's so
many different examples.
And I mean, maybe I can just
think of like all the times
that my kids have told
me how we've screwed up.
And, I actually just think that,
when you screw up,
you should just say that,
and just be honest about it.
And so, you know,
I look at like our Rewind video
that we did two years ago.
It was the most disliked
video on the internet.
- What was that?
Maybe I was in under a rock someplace,
but the most disliked...
What is this video?
- You were under a rock.
Every kid on this video,
they know what I'm talking about.
They know about this video,
that other videos on
YouTube had taken years
to have this many dislikes.
And then our video, in a matter of weeks,
sorry, in matter of a week, of days,
it became the most disliked
video on the internet.
And so I just was like,
"Yeah, the video was cringey.
My kids were like, "It was cringey."
I was like, "Okay, it was a cringey video.
So what?
We made the worst video,
like the most disliked video, fine.
Like, we'll make something
different next year."
And so sometimes you just
got to go with, yeah,
we made a mistake.
Things didn't go well.
So I can tell you, like,
at that moment, it was not...
people at YouTube were not
feeling good that the video
was becoming the most disliked
video on the internet.
But you learn from it.
And, I think having some
humor about it too sometimes,
is, you know, when you can,
when it's something like that,
where you can just say,
"Let's just laugh and move on."
- No, and I have to say,
it takes an incredible
security to bring up, you know,
if you asked me to bring it,
and I have them,
my major failures over the last
year, three years, 10 years,
there's a part of my brain says,
"Sal, don't bring it up.
Then people are gonna know,
you know, all your weaknesses."
It takes a lot to bring that up,
but really appreciate that.
We have another question from Imani.
- I was just curious,
what strong women have inspired
or influenced you to
become the powerful leader
that you are today?
- Who has inspired me?
Well, many people along the way.
My mom definitely inspired me.
And as a kid,
I was always really
impressed with Marie Curie.
And she was my icon as a kid.
She is someone who holds two Nobel Prizes.
And I don't think there
are a lot of other people
who have achieved that
in different fields.
And her daughter also has a Nobel Prize,
which I always thought
was really impressive.
So she was one of my icons.
But I would also say
that a lot of the people
who mentored me
and helped me get to where I am,
they were not always women.
In fact, most of the time they were men,
because most of the people
in positions above me at Google,
in tech, were men.
And there were a lot of super
supportive mentors that I had.
And I always remind people, like,
whether they're a mentee or a mentor,
that anyone,
like, anyone regardless
of their backgrounds,
you can mentor someone.
They don't have to look
like you or be like,
you can just find someone who is talented
that you wanna mentor,
and, again, your mentors
can be different from the
backgrounds you came from,
and they can be really helpful to you.
So I'm very thankful
for all the people who
mentored me along the way,
even though they came from
different backgrounds than I did,
and they definitely helped me,
and I definitely learned from them.
- Absolutely.
And you know, I know we're running low.
I could talk to you for hours.
There's so many questions I have
about your life, about YouTube.
I know we touched on
the subject of learning.
Obviously Khan Academy is
very focused on learning,
and YouTube has been a
big part of that journey,
when I was making content for my cousins,
and still do.
I made three videos that I
uploaded onto YouTube yesterday,
so I'm still very active there.
What's your dream,
if you fast forward five, 10 20 years,
for, you know,
I don't know if you
think in terms of legacy,
but, you know, the impact
that you wanna have through YouTube?
- So we definitely think about YouTube
and how we can continue to grow it.
And I'm always just amazed
of all the new topics
and new ways that we can enable voices
around the world to come
and to share their story.
And so part of our goal
is to enable the next
generation of storytellers
and to help them be able to do
that and to make a business.
And the flip side of that
is that we can have
incredibly compelling content
for people around the world, on any topic.
And so if you look at YouTube,
I see that we bring many value.
And of course, like, you know,
enabling all the fun
videos and music videos,
but we're also dealing with a
lot of really important topics
that just were not talked about before,
whether that involves
mental health issues,
or hearing from people
of different backgrounds
that never were represented
on media traditionally,
like, those are really compelling
and important points of view.
- You know, one last question,
it feels like there's two competing winds.
There is one wind where there's
more tools and resources,
YouTube, Khan Academy, you know,
all the other things that Google provides,
that are enabling the
individual to publish,
to express themselves,
to discover points of view, to learn.
It really does feel like
we're an inflection point,
a renaissance, so to
speak, in human society.
On the other side,
there are reasons why
people can get cynical.
It feels like we are more polarized
as a country or as a world.
It feels like, you know,
inequity is growing.
It feels like people aren't
listening to each other anymore.
You know, the climate's in trouble.
If there's a young person watching...
And there's a pandemic,
and people are feeling
isolated and lonely.
What message can you give to someone
who's kind of trying to
navigate these two currents?
- YouTube does enable people
to connect with each other as humans.
And there's something very human
about the fact that people
are, a lot of times,
going to YouTube and
talking about how they feel,
what their deepest challenges were,
about diseases they have,
and there's something really cathartic
about people going and
sharing the challenges
that they have.
And we've seen other people
really be able to relate
and benefit from that.
So I do see a human connection
that's incredibly powerful on YouTube
for us to understand each
other more as humans.
And I've also seen that
there's an incredible amount
of good that comes,
whether it's something
like the 20 million trees
that are being planted
and organized on YouTube,
or fundraisers to support
people during hard times.
And so I do see that YouTube
can be used for all of
kinds of good outcomes.
And I encourage you to use
like YouTube and all social platforms,
if there's a cause you believe in,
you can make a difference,
you can make a video,
you can organize groups,
and I encourage you to speak your voice,
and now's the best time
ever to be able to do that.
So I encourage you to do what's important
for you and to speak up.
- No, thank you so much
for that. I'm inspired.
I'm gonna go use social media
to try to change the world.
Well, Susan, thank you so much.
I know you're incredibly busy.
And thank you for making
the time out for all of us,
and all of the students who are watching,
and their questions.
And, you know, I'm excited
to be part of your journey,
which you are empowering Khan
Academy on so many levels,
and see where we can take the world.
- Well, thank you.
And I'm glad we have been
part of your journey too.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
As you could tell,
you know, these conversations,
when you have a guest like Susan,
I could talk for hours,
so much to learn from,
and I find her to be incredibly inspiring.
And you know, I've known
Susan and her family
for many years now.
And you know, every time I chat,
I never cease to be impressed
by what, actually, her and her sisters
and her mother are accomplishing
on a regular basis.
So I thank you all for joining.
We're actually going to have...
Our next show is March 10th.
The guest is Mark Sternberg.
It'll actually be hosted
by Khan Academy's Chief Learning
Officer, Kristen DiCerbo.
And they're going to be talking...
This is Mark Sternberg from
the Walton Family Foundation,
and we'll talk about philanthropy
and learning and impact on education.
So I look forward to
seeing all of y'all there.
Have a good weekend.
(bright music)